[Music]
in Assassin's Creed Valhalla you will
relive the epic saga of the Viking
invasion of England
you play as a var a Viking from Norway
who will lead his or her battle-hardened
warriors across the North Sea to the
British Isles a var is driven by an
ambitious goal to build a thriving Norse
settlement in a hostile land it is time
we go a Viking today we raid that
tomorrow we may built England is a Dark
Age tangle of broken kingdoms and
warring dynasties a land of opportunity
and riches as you prowling Glyn's rivers
by longship you may Rhea locations you
spot from the shoreline ground your ship
and blow your horn to lead your raiding
crew into battle
your crew will assist you in all your
raids fighting enemies battering down
doors and stealing cargo too heavy for
one set of arms whatever riches and
resources you pillage may be used to
develop your settlement giving you
access to useful services better tools
and new settlers at the heart of your
settlement is the Alliance map it will
serve as a record of the allies you have
made and a guide for future
opportunities the Viking Age was a time
of warriors and legends in Valhalla you
will find the largest variety of enemies
ever assembled in an assassin's Creed
game
every archetype offers a unique
challenge some will coordinate with
their allies for special attacks while
others will use nearby objects to their
advantage
including the bodies of fallen warriors
to face these attacks you must find and
exploit your opponent's weaknesses to
gain the upper hand take the fight to
your foes with a host of brutal new
combat abilities snare them with a
Viking harpoon pummel them with throwing
axes incapacitate them with the new stun
system to keep them at a distance or
finish the Marvel
jool will any two weapons you wish to
unleash a deadly combination of attacks
customize your fighting style as you see
fit and become a legendary Viking
warrior
[Music]
all combinations of weapons are
available to dual-wield including to
shields
not all situations call for violence in
this new land a Viking must find a way
to adapt as a Ivar is not welcome in
England you may need to outsmart your
enemies avoiding unwanted attention in
towns and bustling cities use a VARs
hoody and cloak to blend with crowds and
slip past watchful eyes an unseen hunter
among the people
[Music]
from capital cities and villages to the
dense forests and rolling hills of
England exploration is vital to keeping
yourself sharp you must feed off the
land of you hope to endure hunt and
forage to replenish your health and
fortify your equipment such pagan
temples and Roman ruins for new
activities and challenges to strengthen
yourself and your settlement
the more you explore the more of
England's secrets you will reveal but as
you push deeper into England the enemy
will push back in a series of climactic
moments Assassin's Creed Valhalla will
feature massive assaults in which you
who lead a Wars army into battle against
heavily guarded Saxon fortresses
[Music]
fight for your land and tomorrow we
rebuild the forest
Assassin's Creed Valhalla will transport
you to wondrous and haunted lands
inspired by Norse myths and England's
pagan roots it will challenge a surprise
Thank You Bo with unforgettable
characters thrilling triumphs and tragic
losses giving you the chance to live
your own Viking saga
[Music]
[Music]
Assassin's Creed Valhalla available
November 17th
[Music]
[Music]